une histoire au micro bonjour je vais
essayer sans rire pour une fois de vous
présenter le débat du siècle qui a lieu
ce soir et qui verra s'affronter
monsieur georges bach premier ministre à
monsieur raymond marché secrétaire
général du parti communiste côté je
crois qu'on fait de grands signes en
régie va pas il fait du tout c'est
vraiment papier effectivement je l'étais
mais à l'envers
excusez moi c'est monsieur raymond barre
premier ministre à monsieur georges
marchais secrétaire général du parti
communiste
le tirage au sort ayant désigné monsieur
raymond barre c'est à vous monsieur
raymond barre d'ouvrir ce débat sur tf1
je veux une grosse [ __ ]